[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum we have a wonderful
guest today we always have a wonderful
guests but in this person individual is
a delight I've met her at cons she's
always so sweet and charming and really
freaking smart and talented and I really
enjoyed talking with her Bonnie Wright
if you would like this episode we urge
you to stick around because we talk
about mental health life all that stuff
that really helps everyone out there
it's not just a celebrity chat and we
hope you get something out of it and I
think that the show has been a little
more successful because we keep it real
here so if you really enjoy this episode
I I hope you'll subscribe and listen to
more episodes because I think you'll
learn something uh the uh handles on
socials Ryan at inside of you pod on X
or Twitter
inside of your podcast on Instagram and
Facebook that's right you can watch on
YouTube and all that uh you can go to
the inside you online store and get tons
of Smallville merch signs scripts
pictures uh ship keys from the show and
a bunch of cool inside you merch new
tumblers and zip up jackets that are
dope
um so really appreciate it um also my
band sunspin go to sunspin.com get a
zoom with me listen to our music we're
coming out with a new album we've got
vinyls on the inside of you online store
available
um actually sunspin.com is where you get
your vinyls there's not many vinyls left
we made vinyls Ryan
very exciting it's very exciting very
exciting stuff
um weird wild stuff and you could also
for upcoming cons go to my link Tree on
at the Michael Rosenbaum on
Instagram and you can see you know I'm
on Cameo and where I'm going Tom Welling
and I doing cons and evening events with
me and Tom and so much stuff fun stuff
and I hope you'll keep supporting the
podcast by joining patreon.com inside of
you to give back to the show if you're
enjoying it and um yeah it keeps us
going without you we couldn't do it so
without further Ado let's get into the
fascinating wonderful Bonnie Wright it's
my point of view you're listening to
inside of you with Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode and any we
air before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
did you did you come from like a um
a family that was very proper or very
you know because sometimes The
Stereotype is and look my my dad's not
English but he was you know I grew up
with someone who was you know
emotionally not there so I'm just
wondering sometimes you know uh I wonder
how you know upbringings from friends
yeah how was your uh sort of life I
wouldn't say proper in that like
um
in that you know manners were more
important than emotions
um so I definitely was able to express
my emotions before I worried like how I
looked or how I sat at the table but at
the same time yeah I definitely was
caught out often by my parents of doing
something that was I don't know elbows
on the table or eating with my mouth
full all those obvious things that I'm
pleased they taught me how to do oh see
my parents didn't really do that and
that's hence you've seen me and you're
like that's why he's this guy but you
know what my Dad did do did do what he
did do what he did
was I remember him yelling at me one day
at the kitchen table because I had we
were eating meat I don't remember
meatloaf my mom had made this meatloaf
oh my God
me I don't want to talk about it but I
remember I had milk I had a glass of
milk I felt like a glass of milk and he
goes take that milk away from the table
right now put it away you don't you
don't have milk at the dinner table
and I I don't to this day know why
no sense like the pairing is great you
should you should try it yeah but they
never talked about any leaning or
putting my elbows on the table or uh
were I mean your parents seemed like
they were jewelry they had a jewelry
store right yeah yeah they still do so
yeah they still yeah how many years
oh
uh uh probably 4 45 years they've been
working together or maybe more
long time what's it called right jewelry
uh write and Teague so my mum's last
name is Teague yeah really so yeah their
whole life and work and everything is
together do you find jewelry interesting
or do you like you do yeah it's been
pretty hard not to I guess yeah well I
think to not just jewelry how it looks
but also I respect their like
craft behind it and the the technicality
behind it and I feel having grown up
around that and then also growing up
around everyone's incredible technical
skills and crafts on a film set I feel
like I have great respect for people who
are really good at their field right
when your husband
ask you to marry him when he gave you a
ring did he go to your parents for the
ring yeah I also knew I'd be so picky
that we actually like designed it
together so it wasn't it wasn't a
surprise really yeah I wanted to be part
of the yeah the choosing of the stone
and the making it with my parents did he
get a discount from your parents
well they have been pissed if he didn't
ask them to oh yeah that would just be
you would have gotten married to him
probably you'd be like are you kidding
me you got it all wrong yeah right it's
like your parents owning a big hotel and
he's like I'm gonna stay somewhere else
yeah it's just rude there's no matter
why when it's just there for you you
don't even have to make it it's ready
yeah but then he probably thought I
would have been like paranoid at the
thought of maybe I don't know it's too
easy she's gonna think that it was so
easy so I just went to her parents I
took advantage but that's not how it
worked no no
considering I don't wear any other
jewelry that's by anyone else but my
parents so it's not even like there's
stuff styled into my life that's not
made by them but most of the stuff you
do wear is from your parents yeah all of
it I've never wait what what you've
never owned any jewelry other than what
your parents have made no
well I I love it so much and it's there
and it's accessible it's like a girl's
dream just having like a jewelry box
that's just never ending you can call
whenever you want you're like what do
you call your dad Dad yeah not Papa what
did the English say just uh Dad yeah
just daddy well Daddy Daddy not his dad
I want it what do you call and say
um
I really want this necklace like a
necklace that's you know made of
whatever could you guys do that for me
I've never really done like custom
things with them because that's not
really what they do but I feel like
anytime I'm like in their workshop or
their space I you know try things on and
no that looks so nice and do you just
take it sometimes or just given in that
way but often most the time when I get
new jewelry is uh like every birthday is
usually when I get a piece of jewelry do
they ever say no Bonnie you cannot have
that it's too expensive you need to sell
them sometimes like you can have that in
silver not gold I'm like okay fine oh my
gosh that's amazing I mean were they
were they
tough on you at all or were they you
know sort of like
um we just want you to be happy because
some you know parents are different some
parents are like I want you to do this
you're gonna go to school you're gonna
get an education you're gonna do this
and others are just sort of like I don't
really care I'm not you know yeah I feel
yeah there was never a pressure to do a
certain thing or like continue education
or kind of act or different things like
that was very much like
are you do you like this idea are you
happy if you're happy then great I think
they're definitely people who love and
seek like life experiences that are
challenging and inspiring so if they
feel like I'm being challenged and
inspired then they probably think it's
the right
way to go I'm sure there's been times in
my life where they've kind of hold held
their opinions and let me figure it out
for myself as we all should make
mistakes and do different things but
there was never yeah like a
a pressure so to speak I mean I
definitely they definitely have a strong
work ethic and they they are very
um creative and they like to produce a
lot of things so that kind of level of
uh
expression sort of like inadvertently
like they just just from them doing it
was enough for you to go I need to do
this I want I'm compelled to do this
yeah I definitely think I was never
going to become like a lazy person or a
like a non-creative person
what about your brother he's uh an
artist he went to Art School 2 and
studied Fine Art and he yeah so he also
is in
the creative world does he ever ask for
residuals from the Harry Potter movies
because I I read that is it true that he
was the one who was reading the uh the
books and then he says to you
um you know you just remind me of Ginny
Weasley yeah he was really specific
people like have heard that they were
making them into movies and auditioning
and he was like you need to go for the
role of Ginny Weasley I was like okay
don't even know who that is or like what
this book is but it sounds fun did you
read it before you so yeah before I went
to the first audition I read the first
book
um which Ginny isn't really in that much
at all so I didn't really get a sense of
her she obviously comes through more in
in the second book
um but I
yeah it was very much
you know I looked up to my brother
massively and was where I know of him so
if he had like an idea I was like yeah
that sounds good
and I'm grateful he had that great
casting ability to I mean what are the
odds though could you imagine your
brother just goes you should be this
character go find a way to audition for
one of the biggest movies ever that I
guess you knew the books were huge so it
was potential that the movies were going
to be getting but like I I mean where do
you even go is it something that I mean
where did you grow up in London so they
just had casting in London no it wasn't
like an open casting so my mum I think
like I think they came home from work
and we were like we wanna we wanna find
out how we get an audition in Harry
Potter my parents are like
I have no idea we don't know anything in
anyone in the entertainment industry so
my mum being clever and like ready for
the challenge of like figuring it out
called the Publishers in the UK which is
Bloomsbury Publishers they gave her the
casting casting director's number uh or
contact or whatever she contacted them
and they said okay sure if you want to
send in some pictures of Bonnie and if
she could write a couple sentences of
who why she wants to play Ginny and what
did you say I don't know my mum still
has the little the sentences somewhere I
wrote down I'll have to find it I think
she's confident and smart and I think
um I'd be a great Jenny
um you're a nine yes I was nine and then
I went yeah for in total just two
auditions one just with the casting
director and then the second with David
Hayman abduser and Christopher Columbus
the director how how big was the uh how
how many lines did you have for this
audition so I didn't even so because
Ginny had no lines in the first film the
actual line I had in the film which was
one line was given to me on the day
Chris Columbus was like
which is my good luck to Harry
um so I actually read Hermione lines
because they didn't have any other scene
for me to read so they were like okay
you're gonna have to just read this
character
so I read yeah and were you nervous
yeah I was nervous I think I I've done
some plays in school but nothing is
really big I honestly did not think I
was gonna get it I was just like this
could be fun let's go see what on
auditions like you know I wasn't I was
someone who as a kid like loved taking
part in everything but I was never and
still not like I not competitive like I
love like for instance I used to love
sports but I never probably would have
gotten anywhere because I just wasn't
competitive so my brother and I were
just like let's go and just figure like
check this out kind of thing and did not
you know just walked away from the first
audition being like I don't know what
that was you know forgot about it that
was fun moving on and then it was quite
a while after where I when I actually we
got like the call back to then come and
meet
um David Heyman and Christopher Columbus
and I was like then I was like way more
nervous than that I was like oh gosh I'm
using with the guy who uh found America
no no it's not that Christopher Columbus
come on not that one
um please there was the other one
um but yeah so I was like pretty nervous
wow yeah and then
still you know I just was like oh anyone
going for this audition has probably
been acting since they were like
crawling around in commercials I don't
know like since they were babies
so yeah and I think you know a lot a lot
of us hadn't had any experience with
When We Were cast in those movies and I
think that was a good thing in a way
because all of us were kind of
open for the experience and we didn't
have too much of a idea or like
a kind of we weren't overly sort of
aware of ourselves or prepared or
prepared we're just kids
yeah and that was all of them that was
Matthew Lewis our friend
um Neville Longbottom that was Tom
Felton yeah who hadn't done much right
he had done yeah the borrowers do you
remember that no that's a great film
that's great oh so he had he had done a
little bit and Daniel had done a bit
Phelps Brothers they hadn't done
anything they hadn't done anything
so yeah a lot of people that's got to be
comforting knowing no one else knows
what they're doing either except for the
older guys yeah I think the hardest
thing for me was when I had my scene
they'd already been sort of halfway
through the shoot so when I stepped on
you know that that kind of everything
had been a bit uh figured out and so I
was definitely very
nervous and felt like I'm just totally
in the deep end of the pool like what am
I doing
um but I was really lucky Julie Walters
who plays my mum in the film Mrs Weasley
really took me under her wing and saw
that I was probably just like a deer in
headlights just what is going on I don't
know anything about anything do you
still talk to her
I haven't seen her in a long time but
yeah we still are in contact and she
yeah she really made me feel safe and
like I was meant to be there so I'm very
grateful for that I mean you know what I
think I think like okay the books you
know even in the books well how many all
the books come out when the movies were
being made no so everyone's fate of
their character wasn't even right
because if you knew that you ended up
with Harry
at the end like if you knew it from the
beginning you'd be like well they've
gotta I mean this is a part that has to
keep going but you didn't know that
inside he was brought to you by neuro
hacker Ryan what if I told you
that you could have extreme Focus energy
feel better by taking something a couple
times a month
that'd be great yeah well it's here
quality of mind it's something I've been
working on
obviously not working on but I've been
using and it is just extraordinary how
something can work so fast usually for
me anyway it takes some you know if you
take something and they're like oh wait
three or five years and you'll you'll
start to with this I started feeling it
right away I started feeling more
focused I started having more energy
more clarity this stuff works for me
quality of Mine by neuro hacker
um
it really is amazing it combines 28 of
some of the most research-backed
nootropic ingredients on Earth
and an ultimate brain feel formula
qualiamine it's been changing lives for
years now Ryan if you deal with brain
fog like me memory lapses like Ryan
sluggish thinking like everyone try
qualia mind it's an all-vegan formula
with potent bioavailable ingredients
this company is a hundred percent
transparent no proprietary Blends in
fact if you don't have clearer thinking
in 100 days
they'll give you your money back nothing
else out there Comes Close guys I told
the story of that I got this I thought I
had ordered it because I maybe saw it
online it just came to me and I just
started using it not even knowing they
were a sponsor at the time and I noticed
that it started helping me so I kept
taking it and here I am so clear crystal
clear you know uh Ryan as you know I get
asked to advertise a lot of products and
I like to pick products that work for me
so when I'm telling people out there hey
I know these products work for me and
that's why I share them with you and you
know I deal with being sluggish all the
time and brain fogs and all that stuff
but you know the proof is something
directly that moves moves it to the top
of the list for me
um then for my mental performance by far
Focus memory willpower uh my experience
of adding qualiamine to my brain health
supports regimen has been pretty
freaking profound if you've been
listening to me in 2023 and you're still
not prioritizing your brain health then
listen closely
because adding nootropics to my diet
helped my willpower and productivity go
through the roof
again neural hacker has a special deal
receive 100 off your first bottle which
is just 1.95 a day way less than a basic
cup of coffee and with way more benefits
try it for a hundred days if you aren't
100 satisfied 100 money back guarantee
see what one of the best brain fuel
formulas on Earth can do for your
mindset go to neurohacker.com IOU and as
a listener of inside of you use code IOU
at checkout for an extra 15 off your
first purchase that's neurohacker.com
IOU to try qualiamind with code IOU to
experience life-changing mental
performance these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease this
message is sponsored by discover did you
know you could reduce the number of
unwanted calls and emails with online
privacy protection the latest Innovation
from discover discover will help
regularly move your personal info like
your name and address from 10 popular
people search websites that could sell
your data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
how many books were out by this time
I think there were four or three
definitely three maybe four
and but no one told you what was wrong
didn't know
so yeah I mean every time a book came
out you know I was there other bookstore
the day it came out like everyone else
like reading it and it was always hard
because I you know I loved the world I
loved the story I love the book but of
course you're not not going to be
reading the book and every time Ginny
pops up you're going to be like oh
what's she doing kind of thing so it was
always quite a disjointed reading
experience because you kind of were
reading it like for the story and The
Wider narrative and then also just
projecting oh gosh I might have to do
this now in in the film and when yeah
but when did you know
like did they tell you after the first
one that you're coming back
um yeah yeah I think
too I think that I can't even remember
now but I think they knew they were
gonna make two and kind of like made
everyone commit to the two but then for
a lot of the films it was just like they
kind of committed just one at a time and
then I think by
the fourth or fifth one it was like okay
everyone you gotta commit to the end now
like you're either in it or not which I
get if they didn't want someone being
you know that character and everyone
associating that actor with their
character and then suddenly not
completing the full you know eight films
so
so yeah I mean I think it was pretty
obvious that they were gonna make them
all and they were very successful so
yeah did you uh
was did you remember anyone ever getting
fired or was supposed to play a part and
then they didn't continue it and someone
else besides obviously you know Richard
Harris passed away and so Michael Gambon
yeah
um not that I remember
you're in privy to that I wasn't privy
to that but there wasn't anyone you know
who came and then they sort of
disappeared
um that I was aware of right unless they
were very good at you know hiding there
who did you notice like what comes to
mind when you think of like besides
yourself
how much you grew as an actor but who
else when you were watching because you
really started with all these young kids
your peers who did you notice wow they
really became a great actor they they
really impressed you it was I Phil
Rupert who plays Ron I feel like his com
his just ability to play that comedic
timing and his ease of his the way he
played Ron was just so brilliant to
watch I feel like
as we all were kids playing kids I feel
like there was a massive part of Ron
probably inside him as his own character
but I just feel like
yeah there were parts of his character
that became more challenging and not
just this comedic kind of role so it was
always lovely watching him and I think
he was very effortless in the way he
acted where it seemed that way I'm sure
it wasn't in his practice but
um I also think you know
um there's obviously Harry Ron Hermione
but then there's also Neville Luna and
Ginny that really kind of clubbed
together as this kind of group in the
fifth um film with Dumbledore's Army and
then they really go through to kind of
be their kind of Sidekicks I guess in
some of the big Showdown moments so I
really enjoyed working with you know
Ivana and Matt and having that big
opportunity we had for our characters to
just get just that bit more into the
action and it was really lovely to like
work alongside them as we kind of had
that opportunity and I think all of us
the three of us were like very grateful
for that
for our characters so it was nice to
share that together what about your
parents what are they thinking now
that this your mom helps you sort of
find the Publishers who find this who
you get an audition and you meet Chris
Columbus and you get the part you have
one line that you improvise on or they
gave you on set and they're like oh okay
that's cute she's part of this big thing
but you know when did they go oh my gosh
this is you are a part of the you really
are part of this yeah I think it was
also sometimes even when we were filming
it hard to Fathom the scale as it was
like growing into this phenomenon and I
think often it was really weirdly the
premieres that made you kind of just
just the noise of the fans in Leicester
Square and hearing like oh whoa it it's
a huge this is a massive deal and you
know every year we I went to the
premieres in my family and it always
felt like they were the moments where we
kind of looked at each other like what
is this what what are we in like this is
wild
um so it was always fun to to feel feel
those moments because often it was such
a kind of close-knit community on the
set sometimes it didn't even just became
really normal you know as life does
whatever you your normal is
um so those were kind of cool
um but I don't know I mean I'm sure they
were
as any parent is like worried as well as
excited just to make sure that I feel
yeah safe protected you know happy still
doing it you know I think you from 9 to
19 years old as I was in the series like
that's a massive
period of your life where like a lot is
going on I mean you're really growing up
yeah and you still have a lot to do I
mean 19 is still young you know so but
those are like that's 10 years of your
life that's half of your first 19 years
you're on set you're experiencing this
world Fame how did you take it like when
did people recognize you instantly
yeah I mean obviously as the character
grew it was like an inevitable
um uh thing that would grow into being
more recognizable I mean I feel on the
scale of
some of the other actors I feel
you know I had a relatively like I could
still have a normal life you know I took
the tube to school and I went you know I
lived in the heart of London and I was
kind of out and about and doing my thing
you know there were some days where you
did suddenly be like oh my God I want to
you know run away and hide in a box or
something and then other days it was
like kind of forgot that I was
played this big character
um so ebden flowed and I think as you're
going through those kind of awkward
teenage years sometimes it's quite
difficult because you often just want to
kind of be swallowed up with the crowd
as you sometimes do as a teenager yeah
in those awkward days or moments when
you don't feel great so that was
sometimes challenging just when you're
kind of figuring out who you are anyway
and then people have this idea of who
you are right it's like a oh yeah I
guess I'm that person but I'm also like
all these other people that I'm figuring
out yeah were you um it just seems like
I was so immature I'm still immature but
I I feel like if I had that sort of Fame
I don't know I might be like you know
kinda acting a certain way maybe in
front of my parents like um you're
talking to a star hello Jeweler listen I
mean were you at all did you ever did
your mom ever have to put you in place
you're like all right listen Miss
actress do you remember being a young
actress you know actor and then like
listen all right you're you're not in
this house I mean do you remember any of
that I don't think I ever I hope was
never like that it was never like put in
my place from my behavior I think it was
more just sometimes realizing the
opportunity and privilege I had through
that role and what I was able to do I
think my parents like kept me
level-headed in that way but I honestly
think
all of us because we were we had each
other and we were the same age and we
were kind of experiencing this thing at
the same time I think it was much easier
than what I could maybe imagine being
like a single child actor on a
predominantly you know adult set because
you are you kind of don't know exactly
where you where are you still a child or
are you now just entirely a professional
so
I kind of loved the fact that we were
all a similar age and
off camera we were doing our classes
together and studying and just doing
normal kid things and teenage things so
yeah that kind of was super helpful it
felt less isolating in that way which is
I think when you start to think you're
above others when you begin to be a bit
isolated hey there folks it's Michael
Rosenbaum and boy have I got a huge
announcement for you this has been a
long time comment and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're gonna make
it a lot of fun we're planning a q a
maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there I think you
you know it's oh it's also upbringing
and how you treat other people and you
know some people don't have that and
they become something that they probably
wish they hadn't become and uh it's good
to have good mentors good people around
you good friends around you and you know
especially when you're growing up you're
growing up in in in movies you're
growing up in this huge franchise so
it's got to be difficult even though you
you know you seem normal you know you
seem like everything's going and when
you look back and like it was relatively
normal as as normal as it could be but
um did you ever deal with any sort of
like anxiety or any kind of depression
like as a kid yeah I mean I definitely
feel
there was anxiety towards sort of
you know performing and doing the best
thing is the pressure like as my
character built for instance it's like
oh gosh will I do justice to this
character that people love you know so
that was always kind of hard to do
especially when you know inevitably
a lot of the scenes of every character
kind of was chopped down from the book
to the film so you kind of didn't really
have as much to kind of show in the film
so sometimes that was a little
disappointing because there were parts
of the character that just didn't get to
come through
um because they weren't the scenes to do
that so that made me feel like a bit
anxious or just frustrated I guess yeah
yeah because as great as you were in in
the movies it's like you know some
people say you were you know you were
underserved or like you know it's like
you know the book she should have been
more explored this character was yeah
better you know you could have they
could have made it you know and then of
course the the contrast or the the you
know I'm sure they thought we have so
many so much to do and so little time
and whatever but I'm sure it was a
battle the older you get and the more
you realize this is an integral part of
the movie yeah the franchise and I want
my character did you have conversations
with the producers about it I mean not
really I just don't think you I mean
there was just no room for much change
in those scripts you know what I mean
it's like there was a million Executives
like going through them all and I think
what I maybe took which I don't take so
much to now is I kind of felt that like
you know maybe my anxiety was about like
oh I'm going to be seen as like badly
portraying this character rather than
later realizing well I wasn't really
given the opportunity to do that so it
wasn't really my
you know fault exactly yeah and you know
when when fans do share that kind of
disappointment and they they do it in a
way that like we know
and you know that's the same with every
character I mean if only they could have
been five hour long
movies but it would have taken probably
two years to film each one or something
you know I think about like you know
I've talked to Matthew about it and some
of the other guys and gals and you know
it's in in the beginning it's like be
thankful this is what you're paying it's
not much but that's what you're getting
was there ever a time where you're like
okay we can actually renegotiate now
because I'm not I'm in all of these I'm
in I'm in the second one let's start so
you did renegotiate and all that right
and like in terms of as the films went
on yeah yeah I mean obviously you had
kind of your people to do that and help
you together and understand it but yeah
obviously each kind of
you know that you're integral to to the
narrative and the storyline and the
amount of days I was also filming was
obviously growing too so yeah I feel I
always felt like I was well like
respected for my character and how she
grew and developed and I feel we were
incredibly looked after on those you
know films in the sense of too like the
ability to continue my education was
never was always incredibly supported
and I was given so much to be able to do
that I didn't feel like my life stopped
and I had to just give my entire life to
this film like so that was very
important to me yeah you know the
Forgotten people a lot of times on these
movies and TV shows or whatever are the
crew and how hard they work and not only
that but like
um the first A.D second ad third ad tads
they call them but like a lot of these
people were probably you were seeing
every day or taking care of you and
getting your food and bringing you to
different places is there someone that
you remember like you know they this was
someone who was a good AG who took care
of us I mean so many and so many I often
really try in interviews like highlights
the crew that not only did I was a great
friends with all the fellow cast but I
had incredible friends within the crew
too and it was working around those
people kind of how I said at the
beginning of like being really inspired
by people's technical skills and and
craft was why I then ended up going to
film school was really because I was
amongst these incredible people who were
so good at what they were doing
um and I could notice even in the scale
of the 10 films you know you could see
camera trainees working their way
through the camera department or you
could see people who started as little
as you know just small assistants in the
production design department and working
their way up to you know drafts people
or whatever so it was really amazing to
see how you could move through and you
could grow
um when I was just playing one character
it was nice to see like people grow
through those films and get a lot back
um and yeah I mean there were always you
know there's obviously some people you
spend a lot more time with whether that
that's kind of the makeup and hair
department or the costume department but
I I mean I spent a lot of my spare time
when I wasn't filming or doing school
work in a lot of the other departments
so I spent a lot of time doing different
like work experience or projects that I
had to do for school but trying to
actually do them within the Departments
so and I was so grateful that people had
the time for me and they answered all my
Curious questions
um
and you just don't
you know you don't get that always
people don't have the time to give that
necessary film score yeah it's Phil
you're going to film School while
working on your film yeah in the film
yeah so it's like you're in yeah the
fact that those people gave you the time
and helped you and I mean that's the
best experience that's the best
experience I had you know when I was
at a plan that's a plan it's all right
um but I remember you know being on
shows and asking the DP it's like hey
what what lens are you on now you're on
a 100 so so what is that well you know
you're getting the background's more out
of focus and what you're doing is it's
everybody looks good because but here's
why it's a long lens and you know and
and this is how many feet away is the
ideal just like all these little things
and how to do a wrap around how do you
cross the line all these film things and
I I learned it
on set I never went to film school I
learned year after year day after day
taking an interest directing an episode
on of the show and and it was it's just
a crash course in film and it's just
awesome that you did that yeah it was
incredible and so yeah just so pleased
that I had the opportunity to do that
and I'm so pleased that I was interested
at the time because I could have like
just passed me by and I was like wow I
just was working alongside the like
greatest people in their field you know
on that because we we did luckily have
some of the best technically you know
experienced people and obviously actors
as well so it was like the ultimate
you know watch listen kind of skills
that I picked up on
all right who's the most intimidating
Robbie Coltrane Alan Rickman Richard
Harris Michael gambone
who's who who's the most intimidating
when they walked on site you're like oh
boy I think at first Alan Rickman
um because he was so Snape you know he
wanted us to fear Him
um and it he did a very good job at it
but you could tell that he was kind of
having fun with it too which I then
later kind of realized as I kind of grew
up I was like wait a minute you're like
definitely you know enjoying this kind
of thing and actually when you I had the
confidence to speak to him he was such a
like soft and lovely human voice yeah
can you still hear that voice it's so
deep what are you doing or something it
was like a deep breath I can't even do
it I know you're like as you passed him
in the uh hallway if you ever do funny
things like just quickly this kind of
would just say things in a really Snape
voice like
um but using my name in a sentence you
know and you're like oh my gosh
um and then Michael Michael Gambon was
like
he was kind of the same like you think
he's really scaring at first you're like
Dumbledore you know but then he too had
this very soft like humorous like cheeky
nature to him too which like upon having
the opportunity to have more scenes you
know with him that weren't like massive
Great Hall scenes
you're like oh you're like you're fine
you know you're a human too so that was
always fun
um when that you still had you know you
still definitely hold them on this
pedestal but they kind of you know they
soften and become more human sure like
yeah who was who took their work most
seriously they were they just were in
the zone always they stayed in their
character or they you know they they
were friendly or whatever but they were
in their character that you could
remember they go oh okay I mean when on
set Alan Rickman would definitely be
varian's character I would say
um
who else uh
uh Maggie Smith
um I'm trying to think who else
I don't I feel like because we spent so
much time with them you know there's
moments and memories
oh yeah Ray fines was the most chilling
like actor to work around ever just
because like he he has you know he had
to be so he wasn't coming like he wasn't
funny and making jokes I don't know I
mean a little bit but in in a kind of
like Voldemort way if that makes sense
right so you were kind of like oh yeah I
mean I remember there was one um scene I
had in the last film
um that was kind of during the Battle of
Hogwarts and we're all in this Courtyard
scene and you know if we for a moment
like think Harry is dead and he's just
like basically playing and toying with
me as I'm kind of like calling out and
worried about Harry and it was just like
it's terrifying like the scene was just
almost like he gave so much that it was
so fun to act alongside because it was
just like you have been given like just
the most incredible performance that you
just were like you know what what was
was the director
did you feel like he got very little
Direction he just they let him do what
he was doing
I one I feel like I'm sure he was
probably the type of actor that would
like go kind of quietly and speak to the
director rather than
just because he wouldn't want to break
the character to everyone else you know
kind of thing
um and just be raped asking you know
David Yates like how was that you know
um but I'm sure he probably didn't need
that much Direction like he was you know
from you know he was the beginning he
was like perfect for that role yeah what
about Gary Oldman do you remember Gary
Allman you know I sadly didn't get to be
in many scenes with him and I love him
he's just incredible as an actor and I
just serious black I was just so sad
when he you know when I read that in the
books when he like died I was so sad he
was such a like hopeful character for
Harry to to actually have someone right
um so I was saddened and also just sad
because we wouldn't get to see much of
Gary Oldman after that moment and he's
just lovely yeah so
um I don't really I only really met him
offset to be honest right not really in
character I I brought him Pizza once we
hung out
uh the guy cuts my hair
and uh I walk in there's Gary
and going there for years and I had met
Gary before I met him when he was with
Isabella rossolini when they were
married back in the day
and I was like no money living in a one
bedroom with three guys
in New York and my buddy was working at
this place Carmines in New York it's
Italian restaurants like 11 30 at night
he goes hey Rosie uh he calls me and he
says
Your Heroes here and I go what because
Gary Oldman is about wrestling either
here they're eating I go I'll be there I
had no money I took a cab went across
town and I waited till they were done
and I'm like
21 22.
and I just finally went I'm like hey I
just I had to say hello I'm so sorry to
interrupt Miss rossolini big fan Gary Mr
Holman I'm I'm just uh
huge fan
um I'm an actor and um
where you from
I go
oh I went to college in Kentucky because
Kentucky and I think I've flown over
there on my waywards
and then he laughed and Isabella kind of
smiled at him goes Gary you know
whatever and because you're an actor I
said yeah he goes you want to work with
me so yeah he goes he grabs my hand
and he gives this long beat and looks in
my eyes and goes
you will
wow you will and
and then fast forward I had him sign
that my Dracula I have crossed oceans of
time to find yes but I brought him Pizza
once and and he's the sweetest guy and
you know they always say don't meet your
Heroes but yeah I'm glad I did that's
good that's good he was great
um I know it's probably a tough subject
but like Robbie Coltrane when he when he
passed that's got it that were you close
with him yeah he was he was he was the
definitely he was so ready and open to
be him you know I feel like it took a
lot longer sometimes than the other
adult actors to be like okay they're
down to like talk to us you know Robbie
was always like
Hagrid you know he's that like Uncle
that you want to have that like perfect
teacher that kind of someone to lean on
just fun just like lovely warm fun and
you know just would be like he had such
good memory of like you would tell him
stories and he would like remember them
you know years later and just really
know you and get to know everyone he was
just a very loving giving person that
had just such a big heart and Hagrid was
always one of actually my favorite
characters in the book
um and he just just did such great
Justice to that character and
it was so yeah I mean all of us were so
sad because we did spend a really lot of
time with him he always had so much time
for you and that was always so nice and
always made you feel
you know not like a child or not you
know not that anyone really did I think
that's what made us grow up in a good
way but yeah we it was really sad to to
hear that he had passed and were you
surprised did you know anything about
his sickness I did a little bit not like
in full detail but I definitely you know
having seen him quite recently when we
shot the the reunion thing that like the
Harry Potter reunion thing we did
um that was the last time I saw him and
yeah I mean he kind of
yeah you could tell that and you know
shared that he wasn't 100
um so it was I mean too soon for him but
it was sad and but I'm so grateful that
I did really get to know him and spend a
lot of time uh with him as we all did he
was very like loved to like chat to the
kids and what are you know what what are
your what are you all talking about
thinking about like he wanted to be down
with everyone right he wanted to feel
young yeah for sure was he the one that
you remember out of all the adults the
adult actors that that were there that
you felt was the most fun to be around
or
um were there someone else anyone else
that you really felt comfortable with he
death definitely I was very much on the
top of that kind of being comfortable
and warm and giving and I obviously
spent a lot of time with Julie Walters
and Mark Williams being my parents and
we had so many scenes in the Weasley
home and I definitely got very close
with them and felt very at home with
them so that was always really nice you
know I feel you know I'm reflecting on
the whole series and journey I'm so
grateful that I was a Weasley because I
got all these other scenes that weren't
just being kind of a Gryffindor and a
Hogwarts but we had like all these
additional family family scenes and I
think
the the kind of um
what they represented the Weasley family
and the kind of good morals that they
presented were like a lovely to be like
a part of yeah and it was awesome that
you like even after like you got to do
video games and you did the rides at
Universal yes
I mean how cool is that it's like the
gift that keeps on giving you know you
go to the cons where I met you and you
meet the fans and it's like been all
these years and it's just like it's so
cool but now it's cooler is all the
stuff you're doing now all the stuff
that you were working on working towards
getting tutored on set and then going to
uh College University
film school getting a degree
and now you know directing
and producing your own stuff and you
directed
you know some really good stuff like you
know went to Tribeca one went to Cairns
right I mean that's like what that's
like big stuff and and you know you
directed like actors like Jason Isaacs
who was also in the Harry Potter's hat
and like did you just call him one day
and say hey
I've got a roll for you yeah the first
person I asked to be in something you
know was the first piece I made uh with
that was made basically my graduation
film with David thulis and I like really
had kind of written this role sort of
for him you know in mind and I was so
nervous to ask him but you know ma'am I
very much my mum was like the worst
thing he can say is no like you've got
to ask you know yeah so I remember we
were actually a group of us were in New
York um promoting uh a Harry Potter
exhibition that was opening
um and he was there and I was like okay
this is this is my opportunity you know
and so I kind of explained to him about
it and and everything he's like well
yeah do you have do you want to give me
the script and look I'm really honest if
I don't if the character doesn't speak
to me and I don't like the script like
you know I'm probably gonna say no I'm
going to say no is what I'm going to say
no because the script's very careful
right I was like okay cool no pressure I
hope the script is good and I remember
like I said he was like I like slid it
through his like Hotel like you know
under his door or whatever
and then he liked the script how long
did it take him to read it not that long
I think he got back to me in like two
weeks or something like that and I was
just like oh gosh now I actually have to
direct him you know I was like so
nervous like
to direct someone who's been you know so
experienced but again what was so lovely
is he was willing and ready to you know
and wanted me to thrive in that
experience and so he was just very just
yeah giving I think impatient and just
like you know direct me like this is all
good like let's go you know what's
difficult I think is when I've directed
things I I feel like there's this
pressure you put on yourself that I have
to be great I have to prove to them that
I am worthy that I could do this I want
everybody to see that I am capable that
I am competent and when you can just
relax and just know that you're
confident that of course that takes time
like anything else but it's that that
stuff that I'm like stop stop worrying
about that What story do you want to
tell what is important to you what you
know enjoy these moments instead of
worrying so much about because there's
gonna always be people who hate whatever
you do and so how do you deal with that
yeah I think it kind of Ebbs and flows
and and sometimes it doesn't it comes up
for me way more on projects than others
um and if I if it's been a bit of a
longer gap between a project I am a bit
like oh like this is a kind of a
comfortable moment as I kind of try on
that kind of role again
um I think
yeah I think it's always that you know
if you obsess too much about thinking
you need to be the leader of this group
and like let's go you know I've got all
the ideas and I know everything then
you're not it's going to be stressful
like you say but if you just focus on
the script the story just that scene
also just really lean on the people
you're collaborating with you know
you've hired and them for a reason when
it comes to these other people
um so and I think the best lesson I
learned too is I often used to think
like I need the answer right now or I
need to interpret like how that take
went and quickly now give my direction
like you know and need to always have it
fully formed and I think the best thing
I learn is just know and be okay with
moments where I'm like let's just take a
couple of minutes like I'm just gonna
think before I say and not just
immediately give a direction that I'm
like actually no that's not what I meant
but in that pressure I kind of said
something so I feel like taking my time
and not and being vulnerable I think is
the best thing to do you know really
care yeah and so that people people will
be much more I feel like trust you if
you're like you know what I'm not sure
what we're gonna do next but I just need
a second
um let's talk about it like you know do
this rather than
kind of giving like really confusing
direction that like I don't think she
knows what she wants you know so those
have been good moments but you know
there's definitely been moments where I
haven't taken those beats and pauses and
I have felt and can't you know stressed
I've done that too and just out of my
body like not in the day yes
disassociation like it's almost like you
know it's like yeah yeah because you
want people to think you know what
you're doing and that moment where you
just say you know Scorsese I read
somewhere that he
he will sometimes just take I need 10
minutes yeah he'll go to his trailer
I'll sit down think about things
and you know how meditate and sort of on
the idea and then come back and be ready
to go
um yeah so some people could be holding
and waiting on your word you know it's
like uh you become kind of Frozen in
those moments yeah and also I wonder
like you said vulnerability it's like
being honest with somebody say um what
do you want me to do and I you know
you know to be honest with you I'm not
sure at this moment give me a beat let
me think about that
you know let me let me think about that
I'm not going to give you some answer
that you just that I'm not even I'm not
confident and I would want that too as I
speak to like a DP or a production
designer I would want them to say that
to me not like give me a quick answer
that I'm like that's not that doesn't
feel like a good idea or that doesn't
feel like a you idea you know I would I
would like that given back to me I think
of course of course says he said
something and I said uh what do you want
me to do
no I don't know
I'd be like what your margin Scorsese
um you published a book yeah what I mean
do you just want to do everything is
there anything you don't want now you're
doing a documentary that you're
producing and directing right yeah when
does that start uh we stopped filming in
like three weeks and what's it about can
you tell yeah so it's kind of based on
my book go gently it's probably gonna
have a similar type title go gently
actionable steps to nurture yourself and
the planet that's it yeah so that came
out last year and essentially the book
is about individual actions that we can
be taking around the climate crisis and
making the really large scary big
overwhelming topics feel
kind of like they relate to our
day-to-day life and seeing how we kind
of fit in the broader picture and how we
can be more informed with the choices we
make through what we consume or how we
live and things like that
um so the show is actually going to be
not about the individual kind of action
and more about the collective and
community-based action so I'm basically
taking a road trip from Los Angeles to
Portland
meeting a broad broad spectrum of people
all kind of
doing something for their Community the
climate
um or just kind of having a great
relationship to Nature and the show I
essentially wanted to make a show that
made us think and believe that humans
are great and we can do amazing things
rather than the many documentaries that
already exist out there that talk about
you know
the the serious kind of terrifying
truths of the climate crisis I wanted it
to be more about a celebration of humans
and how we can be good so yes it's going
to be like a four week road trip
um
meeting a lot of different people
staying in places from camping to
um you know hotels to wherever and
um essentially just also just
celebrating the beautiful landscapes
we're gonna go through you know
something I
I was just thinking about this it's like
we the proverbial we
um
we see a fire and what do we do we put
it out right
but we put it out because right now we
see that it's burning something down
it's
um having a negative effect on whatever
it you know
in simplest terms uh
but the environment
is pretty much on fire it's always on
fire you know and but we don't if we
don't see the fire
we assume it's um it's like what I'm
trying to say is it's almost like let's
live in today we have to take care of
today we can't worry about tomorrow and
so environment is so it's so important
and the pollution in the Plastics and
all these things
and you know I'm not great either I'm
good but I I could be a lot better and
it's just like I don't know why it's not
implemented in in high schools grade
schools like just really part of the
curriculum of like this is what we do
this is how we operate and we're we're
taking so long technologically to adapt
to this situation or sort of like you
know the we don't see that the planet's
in crisis unless you're a scientist
unless you believe science unless you
right so I guess it's like how do you
get people to really back it and you do
documentaries you write books you do
this and it's like
it's like you just got to keep waking
people up and saying you can actually
help if there's more of you Bonnie yeah
so yeah I mean I think like what you say
like if if you bring it home and whether
that has to be through someone else's
story who's been more directly affected
and on the front lines of a crisis of of
climate you know whether that's a
hurricane a typhoon uh you know a
wildfire or exposure to toxins like has
just happened in the train crash in in
Ohio like if if you see a story that's
like oh that's just 10 miles from my
house or someone I know's house like as
these stories sadly are going to come
closer to our
sphere and vicinity then you know we are
more likely to react like however well
you can tell a story of someone far away
experiencing something or you know
distant Marine ecology suffering from
microplastics like that is quite far and
hard to like actually put into a scale
that we comprehend but I think
as stories are told you know documentary
or narratively and it brings some
emotion about like we will then more
interact because as much as obviously
science is kind of that core pillar like
sometimes the way it's described is not
a way that like we can kind of get
around or emote or like understand so I
think
that's what I am drawn to like how do we
bring in the humanism and the emotions
to these things so that they become
people even if they're an animal like
they become people
um so and I think that's the power of
like storytelling and
um
and I think people are more yeah just
how we work as human beings like how you
know sometimes we need to be tricked
into certain things to do them for
instance like if you incentivized
actions that you could take to better
your environment you probably would do
it rather than just doing it for the
sake of it you know when you put in
charges on plastic bags in the grocery
store or you know certain things like
that or you get sort of
tax credits or rebates for doing certain
things like we we just are we work that
way if we get incentivized by something
and we get kind of the it's like a child
we are all children it's like would you
like an ice cream if you clean your room
you'll get an ice cream
and I think that's what you know it's
unfortunate about
the government and when we can feel like
oh we're not moving fast enough like
there's only so much we can bully and
feel bad about as individuals when
really those in power are not doing
enough you know and they're not acting
in the emergency state that we need to
act so it's always that push-pull I
think of how
terrible we can feel on our own like I
feel like there's only so far you can
spiral into that kind of doomism when
it's just not helpful you know you have
to kind of like smart like it makes
perfect sense
um well I love it I love that you're
doing that I love that you're so serious
about it and you just don't stop I mean
working with Greenpeace and it just
keeps building and I know you traveled
and you know
um looking out the oceans and the
Plastics and all the things that are
happening and it's just it's a lot to
take on along with your career but
you're also like hey this is part of my
life part of my career is doing this and
making documentaries and writing books
and awesome awesome
all right this is called [__] talking
with Bonnie Wright these are rapid fire
these are for my patrons they're awesome
I love you guys they support the show
they really give back and keep the show
going uh patreon.com inside of you to
join uh here we go Ray H what has been
the most challenging thing to work on
oh
um well probably honestly still Harry
Potter even though like I think in
perspective yeah it was a massive
challenge 10 years stamina
yeah I think when you're a kid you don't
even realize when you're young you can
power through [__] I was like I'm fine
now I'm like yeah on perspective I'm
like wow that was pretty hard oh my gosh
and imagine being hairy yeah I can't
even imagine oh my gosh that's daunting
right
I guess as a kid you're excited and
you're just like oh where do I go next
where do I go next and then all of a
sudden you get old and you're like oh my
God that was when I was I could do it
and I don't know if anybody could do
well people do it I just don't I just
couldn't do it Sophie M can you tell us
about your audition for we already
talked about that sorry Sophie Alan
Rickman did Alan Rickman have an
intimidating presence we we talked about
that so I'm just mentioning your name
your name is Alan Rickman the guy's name
I think is Alan Rickman wow it can't be
but that's what that's what Bryce has on
there
was there anyone else that you were
afraid to work with not that you were
afraid to work with him but we're kind
of uh well yeah we spoke about Ray fines
now I'm like yeah it was pretty
terrifying Maggie she was kind of
serious yeah she was definitely serious
yet Tom n who had the best practical
jokes on the set of Harry Potter oh
definitely James and Oliver Phelps
really yeah I mean they were them you
know are you going on their travel show
I went on the first season
and they asked me to do it so they have
this awesome job what's the show called
fantastic friends fantastic friends guys
that I'm promoting it because I love
those guys good shout out to Dan I might
do a show at my own show cool with Dan
and so uh it'll be cool too I'm trying
to get my buddy John heater to join me
um Julie Jules if you had creative
control over Jenny's role in the H Harry
Potter franchise what would you have
liked to see or imagine she would have
done if she had a larger role I mean we
talked about that but like what's the
one thing you think of oh so many things
I mean I think had development and
relationship with Harry like there's in
the book there are all these little kind
of moments that build up to it and like
give it reason
um so just those nuanced moments of like
their relationship developing would have
been great
um I also feel like there were many more
scenes kind of showing this kind of like
confidence of her which is like through
the Dumbledore's Army scenes or loads of
quidditch she was in obviously she
becomes a professional quidditch player
in her later life so uh I think they
would have helped Maya P what is it like
directing actors we well we worked with
as a child I mean pretty scary but yeah
pretty uh but she did it I was pretty on
it yes do you know there was a play my
French for Rudolph told me this there
was a two-part stage play it's 19 years
later after Harry Potter after the
epilogue I guess and your second child
goes to Hogwarts and shows difficulties
he has with his parents and in his
adventures uh that they go on there was
controversy with the play did you ever
hear about that the cost child play is
that what it's called yeah yeah I mean
it well I don't know did you see it oh
no but yeah it's um I've seen it it's um
I saw it with the original cast in
London when it was first on I mean it
came I mean it was part of the it
obviously it was written by someone else
who wrote the book as a play and lots of
people read the book and then it was
kind of okay to sort of go into
production and JK Rowling kind of was a
supporting kind of producer or some role
on it
um and the biggest question that
everyone wants to know is are they going
to be making
I mean it would be pretty fun because
also the characters you know it's really
about the children it's not about
our characters so it wouldn't be a
massive role it would be really about
like these kids and the new generation
but there's some this particularly yeah
yeah but it would be it wouldn't it
would just be more of a kind of
Adventure yeah so it would be fun
um I but I have no idea if they'll do it
all politics aside JK Rowling and um
what do you think of her as a Creator as
an author as um yeah that's a lovely
question I think brilliant I mean you
know she created this incredible world
that was so deeply layered
um and just a joy to be a part of like
there was just so much material in those
books to help you create this magical
world and when I go back and like read
the first book or watch the first movie
and just like wow like this is just like
exactly what you want stories to be like
to fully Escape into this like entirely
built world that is like solid and real
and I think it's really from you know I
I'm a big lover of
you know the genre of fantasy or sci-fi
and those kind of things so to actually
see someone like achieve a world that's
fully like
you're absorbed in is really cool do you
I guess it's like don't you kind of wish
I think a lot of people wish that if
they go to London if they go to England
it was Harry Potter World everywhere it
just oh it looks like is that based on
Old England and things like that pretty
much is right yeah I mean you know
fantasy probably yeah like obviously
like
like I don't know like the shopping kind
of Street like Diagon Alley and those
kind of things you know there are little
kind of cobbled streets of old shops
that exist in London that you're like
this is the inspiration or all small
towns that exist like that so it doesn't
feel yet very steeped in
that kind of history and architecture
but just in a more odd odd kind of
magical mystical way yeah um but I love
that London is is really a part of the
films having
you know I'm a Londoner grew up in
London and I love seeing those scenes
um in in the films particularly like
some moments they're just like flying on
broomsticks like down the Thames you're
like yeah sure what's your favorite film
out of all of them and what is and
lastly what is your favorite moment for
you as a character
um my favorite film
personally I loved filming the Chamber
of Secrets the second because that was
like a massive step up for my character
and then I love Deathly Hallows part two
because I had all the Hogwarts battle
sequences and I always loved those kind
of high energy moments and there was
like a lot at stake and sadly quite a
lot of characters died so it was like
very emotional
um so that was really fun that even
though it was the last film so it was
kind of sad knowing it was coming to an
end
um but like personally but then story
wise I was loved the Order of the
Phoenix
um which is the fifth one
um
I feel like every day there's like a
different mood you're like oh no I love
the Goblet of Fire
um but favorite moment
um
that's hard and there's a lot of moments
a favorite moment just because I was
like excited to be in the middle of the
scene there's this great scene in the
Battle of Hogwarts where basically like
Bellatrix Lestrange like goes for me and
Mrs Weasley sort of like stands in my
way and they have this little like you
know moment that's written so well you
know there's this great line she Mrs
Weasley and Julie was so excited to say
which is like stay away from my daughter
you [__] or something like that and
like in the weeks like leading up to
knowing that they were gonna film this
scene you know you could tell they were
like you know you know they were like
winding each other up and getting each
other really excited into this scene and
I was just so excited to be in the
middle of it that's awesome um and they
had fun with it and it was good uh you
do any impressions
what
[Laughter]
maybe come on try one of what I think um
can you do an impression of Maggie
um
[Laughter]
Ronald Weasley she said something like
that like 10 points do it again
you're late again
that's so good do you like doing accents
and things and I do when I was younger I
was like obsessed with accents like I
loved accents my mum's side of the
family all live in Australia can you do
one and so I used to a lot like I used
to be obsessed with Australia like I was
like why do we live in London we can
live at the beach like what are we doing
and so every time we're in Australia I
would like have this accent and I'd be
like trying to you know be Australian
and my brother's like shut like you're
not from here and I was like stop you
know like ruining my my
um my character and then my dad is from
Leeds which is where Matthew so I used
to love doing an Northern accent
I wouldn't even know
um I used to like my cousins used to the
front they've been all like long long
words like Mom no I don't want to do
that like I speak like this
like where are you going
what are you having is what everyone
what are you having people say when
you're like what are you having for
dinner or something or like it's just
slower yeah very slow nice like long
elongated I remember him like there was
this band the Arctic Monkeys that he
loves the Arctic Monkeys and he I was I
was like who's this he's like Arctic
Monkeys the way he said it I remember he
goes Arctic Monkeys
the Arctic Monkeys or whatever how he
said it he's gonna get mad at me because
I don't because I don't sound like that
um this has been a treat Jeff fun yeah I
did I told you yeah fun it's it's easy
it's easy with you it's easy with me
yeah
yeah thanks for being here thank you all
right I'll see you later oh what's your
handle oh at this is be right
at this is be right follow her if you
haven't already followed her she's
awesome thank you thank
what you see is what you get
with Bonnie uh she's no BS
when you meet her she's kind and but
she's like you know I'm not you know she
doesn't put up with [__] so why why
would you and she's uh she's smart she
directs she acts she does it all and uh
it was a treat having her here in the
studio thanks for your time Bonnie I
really appreciate you and again if you
like the podcast Please Subscribe write
a review helps the podcast and if you
missed out on something I say all the
stuff in the intro patreon.com inside of
you that really Patron save the show so
join that and support the podcast you
get so many perks for patreon
um
one of which are your names mentioned at
the end of every episode uh zooms with
me on occasion uh YouTube lives we do
private YouTube lives or play some music
and we you guys ask me anything you want
um you get to ask questions for the [__]
talking segment there's so many perks
and it's become a real community and
people really love each other and um
join because you're really saving the
show patreon.com inside of you uh let's
get to the top tiers Ryan I liked how
this worked yeah uh let's try it again I
like looking at the names too all right
here we go it's nice for me I'm gonna do
a voice and he has to
repeat the voice and you guys tell me if
Ryan does a good job
posture Man City Leah s Kristen
little Lisa Yukiko
Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason W
Sophie M see that was pretty good yeah
okay
Raj C Joshua D Jennifer N
Stacy l
Jamal F Channel B
Mike a l dance abramo 99 more San Diego
M Chad W Lee and P Matias Linda M Dave H
Sheila G Brad d
Ray H Tabitha D floors banquet Pier
I've got diabetes
if you're suffering from diabetes get
yourself a bowl of quicker oats right
now uh
[Music]
Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy day Corey
check B Angela f
male s Christine s Eric H Shane R Andrew
M
l
Amanda R
Jen B
Stephanie okay
enjoy l
Jay
Leanne J
Luna R
Michael Stone Age spinal Kindle L
Garrison
um
Jessica me Kyle FM Marisol p
Kaylee J
k l
ol
Mary Louise L Romeo B Veronica thank you
Frank is this is uh what's his face
Nikki l
only
April cassibly
Derek and
jdw Michelle L
ombs
I love it we love you from Michael
rosenbum here in the Hollywood Hills
California I'm Ryan Tates he's Ryan
tears that wave hey guys be good to
yourself that was a lot of fun we'll see
you next week
[Music]